ce qu'on pourra pas dire qu'on n'a pas
parlé d'économie durant cette campagne
ça fait trente jours messieurs dames
bonsoir à vous bonsoir alec aussi dit
emmanuelle latraverse et ottawa
mais celle ci au gie ici à montréal
également on va écouter si vous le
voulez bien d'abord un petit extrait de
stephen harper d'aujourd'hui une crise
dans un secteur particulier pour une
période cours indique qu on doit doit
continuer un plan à long terme basée sur
la réduction d'impôt et des budgets
équilibrés et fasse des hausses d'impôts
et des déficits comme non monsieur a
plus qu'a voulu redonner et envoyer des
questions à ses adversaires en temps moi
en tout cas je fais pas de déficit
le en francs mais sur le on n'a pas
entendu cet extrait l'âme et sur l'a
d'abord sur la question de la récession
là on est muet une chirurgie est ce
qu'on est dans une similaire d'économie
récession pas récession qu'est ce que
c'est que ce débat le séminaire
d'économies va voir enfin ce matin vers
7h30 quand ça c'est canada vont nous
dire sur l'état récession ou pas en
récession
ce qui est intéressant dans ce que je
suis un peu et c'est dire si le seuil de
80% de l'économie va bien il ya juste
20% qui performent pas ça ce serait le
secteur pétrolier et gazier
d'abord c'est le secteur dans lequel il
a mis toutes ses billes faut pas
l'oublier
deux erreurs passées c'est pas tout à
fait exact on a fait une vérification de
fait celle d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
là-dessus justement monde y regarder non
secteur industriel marche pas la
fabrication marche pas alors c'est pas
c'est pas seulement là
un problème de nature pétrolière
actuellement c'est l'économie canadienne
qui tourne pas c'est parce que dans
l'autre extrait qu'on n'attendra pas
mais imaginez la omra peut dire les
étiquettes ne sont pas importants de l
éducation de récession peut-être au port
à ok mais on va s'en sortir mais
l'ironie c'est qu'en ce moment à
commencer par ça serait quoi le résultat
de 7,6 canada c'est que même monsieur
week-end aujourd'hui dans les étiquettes
c'est relatif au cas où finalement on se
fait pas en récession si le problème
pour monsieur harper sait que c'est lui
qui fait campagne sur son bilan
économique
et ça pose problème de voir que le
canada est en récession
ça complique la tâche pour lui d'avoir à
convaincre les canadiens que la
meilleure chose à faire c'est de ne pas
changer son style les chenilles choix
que son gouvernement fait ses priorités
économiques parce que la dernière fois
qu'il s'est présentée devant les
électeurs avec ce discours l'heure
rappelez vous c'est en 2008 en pleine
crise à l'époque gagner la campagne
électorale en tenant ce discours là et
qu'est ce qui était arrivé trois mois
plus tard il faillit être défait on va
pas refaire le film et s'est ramassé a
présenté un des plus importants déficits
volontaire un immense plan de
stimulation économique
donc si tu fais pour monsieur harper le
complément plaidé la stabilité qu'en bel
et bien si bel et bien ce monde
récession se confirme je voudrais
d'autant plus qu' il est un peu tout
seul en ce moment là dans ce bateau là
mais je joue mes preuves c'est el ma
prochaine question alec castonguay
on a l'impression d'avoir oui joe oliver
le musée finances on le voit pas
beaucoup et ils s'ennuient de certains
de ses anciens camarades de mr poulat
qui ne sont plus là à ses côtés ou est
clairement du côté de la campagne
conservatrice on s'ennuie de jim
flaherty parce qu'il aurait été le seul
dès qu'on arrêtait ambre qu'on a renvoyé
au front si on l'avait eu sous la main
demain matin lorsque statistique canada
va probablement confirmer
qu'effectivement le pays est en
récession technique pendant deux
trimestres consécutifs où on a pas de
croissance du pib
on pourrait par contre annoncé qu'une
croissance pour le mois de juin des
résultats qu'on attend et donc on a
peut-être même déjà passé le cap de la
récession et que ça va un peu mieux que
la doxa a été ce printemps que cet hiver
parce qu'effectivement différents types
de récession là on le bo est en
récession
du côté conservateur on ne veut pas
entendre le mot
le conte présente en campagne électorale
en même temps pour les canadiens
comprennent bien on n'est pas en
2008-2009 là on n'est pas dans une
récession qui s'annonce sévère on pourra
voir une croissance économique dans le
reste de l'année qui s'en vient c'est
juste que pour un gouvernement qui
défend son bilan mais ça arrive en
pleine campagne électorale c'est plutôt
mauvais et là on a pas de soldats le joe
oliver est porté disparu on sait pas il
est où on n'a pas de grands piliers
économiques à part stephen harper a
envoyé au front
je voudrais que même le npd lequel
jamais gouverné au fédéral à son pilier
avec andrew thompson qui était ministre
des finances de la saskatchewan qui a
présenté des budgets équilibrés lui on
va le sortir demain puisque côté des
conservateurs on n'aura pas personnes à
sortir savons à quel point ce soit oui
vous il ya met ses environs se demande
pourquoi dieu le veut on le voit peu
j'ai fait une petite recherche
aujourd'hui mais je n'ai voulu 4 juillet
dernier une entrevue à nos collègues de
la sib ici déjà la menace de récession
plane est à ce moment là et il avait été
catégorique en disant qu'il n'y a pas de
risque de récession qui plane sur
l'économie canadienne et qu'ils
prévoyaient même une croissance
vigoureuse pour le reste de l'année
on comprend le temps qu'on sera pas
entièrement fixe et surtout avec des
chiffres de croissance à la baisse que
pour le moment on préfère les garder
peut-être ont la peau puis le lendemain
du budget quand il a fait sa fameuse
gaffe en disant ça c'est une histoire
que les petits enfants de monsieur
empereur régleront c'est l'augmentation
n'avait manqué d'argent à cause de
l'augmentation du plafond du celi ont là
pourvu depuis ce temps alors si on avait
une sibérie ministre et l'homme on en
apprend malheureusement x men à toronto
dans des crimes 128 wifek à peine à
toronto dans son comté briques et des
coupes pour hommes seulement où nenê
comme a dit allegri comme un dialecte on
en a déjà parlé
l'absence de jim flaherty de d'autres ça
se fait sentir
bon par contre ça ces environnements non
les chiffres la tête dure on verra
récession ou pas monsieur trudeau lui
dit pour sortir de ce marasme pour
toutes ce ralentissement faut dépenser
je vais faire le difficile pendant trois
ans le dit la semaine dernière monsieur
mulcair continue malgré tout les
attaques de monsieur à peu continuer à
dire que lui n'en fera pas il va faire
ce qu'il veut faire sans faire de
difficile est-ce que ça devient pas une
position qui va être extrêmement
difficile à tenir pendant les premières
deux jours à la campagne 40 ça va être
difficile à tenir mais ce qui ce que
monsieur walter dix qui est qui va
devoir montrer dans un cadre financier
parce qu'on n'a toujours pas vu son cas
le financer c'est écoutez moi je pour
juger de faire les mêmes choix que d
venant après je ferai pas le
fractionnement du revenu
je serai pas là aux doubles avons des
séries sauf que oui ça c'est vrai les
mais on sait combien ça coûte le
fractionnement du revenu c'est une bonne
chose
l'augmentation du plafond du celi c'est
bon et que ça alors il va falloir qu'ils
quittaient des grosses affaires que
monsieur harper fait que monsieur walker
avant de nous promettre de ne pas faire
et jean va le voir dans son de la
financer il ya un élément je voudrais ça
dépend justement décidé mais on est en
récession ou pas si demain on n'est pas
en récession s'achète une marge de
manoeuvre à monsieur mulcair sûr vous
voyez c'est pas le temps de se lancer
dans des dépenses dans des dépenses paul
la croissance peut être leur père a
alors que si on l'étend récession demain
bel et bien là vous allez entendre
justin trudeau dire vous voyez c'est la
preuve qu'il faut relancer l'économie
est une erreur et c'est là que ça va se
corser entre autres pour pour monsieur
mulcair
parce que quand la seule avenue si on
veut équilibrer le budget c'est à un
moment donné bon d'annuler certaines
promesses dé certains engagements de
monsieur à peu mais objectivement
d'aller jouer du côté des revenus aussi
les impôts des corporations par là une
limite dans ce jeu là et donc la marge
de manoeuvre devient très mince en effet
pour le npd
emmanuel hier à votre émission je crois
que vous avez lancé la bourse la bourse
ou la course électorale et est assez
amusant ce cas-là castonguay vous le
disiez la boussole oui alex castro gay
vous le disais la semaine dernière quand
on voit monsieur trudeau faire campagne
plus à gauche que le npd la boussole
tour et a de la misère à se situer la
halle est en même temps c'est un peu le
monde à l'envers
ceci dit un peu eu un glissement dans
les derniers jours parce que oui
libéraux en campagne à gauche d'une paix
dit parce qu'ils promettent énormément
de dépenses mais ce n'est pas en
permettant au déficit qu'on fait à
gauche compte qu'on est à gauche de
l'autre partie on un peu glissement dans
les derniers jours on a la pression
parce que quelqu'un fait un déficit qui
est automatiquement à gauche on peut
être de droite et est un mauvais
gestionnaire et faire des déficits et on
peut être à gauche est un bon
gestionnaire et ne pas faire de déficit
la saskatchewan et des budgets
équilibrés depuis bien des années
souvent romano sous avance sur un lit de
glace puis il s'éteint c'est un
gouvernement de gauche en défendant des
choix qu'on fait en termes
d'investissements et on est capable
d'équilibrer le budget quand même donc
c'est plutôt le fait que justin redoux
promettre beaucoup de millions qui fait
campagne à gauche il promet de dépasser
lui aussi de leurs mecs dépenser plus ça
nous promet de dépenser plus exactement
alors qu'en terme de difficiles
lorsqu'on verra les cadres financiers de
chacun on peut très bien faire des choix
qu'ils soient un peu plus à gauche sans
nécessairement automatiquement faire des
déficits parce que thomas monter son
plan tient la route on le verra mais ce
n'est pas faux de dire écoutez quand je
fais des choix différemment ben ça donne
automatiquement aussi des résultats
différemment dans les finances publiques
on verra le cadre effectivement coms et
michel on va écouter un extrait gilles
duceppe tourner court dans la poche des
parents par exemple avec la prestation
universelle pour garde d'enfants à la
poche des aînés que le supplément de
revenu garanti avait je ne sais combien
de milliers de québécois québécoise qui
ne savait même pas qui avait drôlement
de revenu garanti dans la poche des
travailleurs avec la formation de la
main d'oeuvre
nous avons protégé nos agriculteurs avec
la gestion de l'offre et nous qui avait
fait passer cette potion à lhassa au
parlement en novembre 2005
unanimement nous avons ramené des
milliards pour la santé l'éducation
nous avons contribué à mettre fin au
scandale des commandites
alors michel c il faut qu'ils regardent
dans le rétroviseur souvenez vous
souvenez vous qu'en fait il a dit on de
fait cette grande chose pour le québec
en 25 ans d'histoire ça c'est une
affaire ou trois ans et demi je sais pas
si les gens vont trouver ça
extraordinaire de voir ça comme ça mais
c'est le problème ne me suis dit c'est
ça c'est que ce qu'on entend chez les
électeurs c'est il répondu revenir au
dessus de ce qu'on aime bien lui mais le
bloc a fait son temps puis là il faut
battre a peur on l'entend adnot et âme
dans ce matin dans les rues du québec
lui pays tout ce qui peut faire quand il
faut que j'assure contre mauvaise
fortune bon gars et dire oui bon on vous
en donner des choses il l'a fait
aujourd'hui moi je crois que ça va être
suffisant pour quelqu'un que les cloches
sonnent partout dans les villages au
québec mais il joue les caïds ou les
capteurs à bord il y en a bondi de 9,1
et l'opinion publique que ceux qui
croient en l'utilité du bloc il n'y a
pas beaucoup de coeur dans les mains il
fait campagne il va jusqu'au bout
emmanuel alec un mot là-dessus mais ce
que de remarquable c'est que quand même
quand monsieur duceppe parle du
supplément de revenu garanti ou la
formation de la main-d'oeuvre citer les
thèmes qui à l'époque animer les
campagnes électorales du bloc québécois
qui était quand même au diapason je
voudrais des choix des enjeux qu'on
mettait sur le radar on était à
l'offensive crème à ses remarques a
prôné au début de la cinquième semaine
de la campagne électorale et que le bloc
on est encore à défendre sa pertinence
dans le débat l'importance sap la place
qu'il a et ça ça c'est assez remarquable
je vous dirais d'autant plus que quand
le discours c'est de dire
le npd ça sert à rien les électeurs ne
comprennent pas il ya quand même une
époque aussi où quand les adversaires du
bloc québécois disaient ça monsieur
duceppe faisait que ça manque un peu de
respect pour 40 quelques pourcents qu'il
appuyait emmanuel michel c'est alex et
tout à coup on se retrouve demain
bonne journée puis quand j'avais dit
manuel on a eu un petit choc et si nous
étions la cinquième semaine
effectivement déjà c'est presque fini
mais la fête du travail où le ca bientôt
là tout ça va prendre un autre rythme il
y aura des chiffres plus de propositions
parce que ça manque de ça manque de
propositions chiffrées touche à la merci